um so I made the mistake of getting into
a house with my ex fiance um and I just
yeah I just don't know where to go from
there we were in the house for like
about 7even months and then she decided
to pull the plug on us and I'm just kind
of confused and don't know where to go
and how to handle it you're a case study
and why we tell people not to buy stuff
with people they're not married to yet
oh I'm so sorry Chris how long ago was
the breakup about 3 months ago who's
living in the house um I moved out
recently and she stay in the house right
now have we discussed when we are going
to sell our house um we have discussed
it and we've actually talked to a
realator about putting it on the market
but she would only walk away with about
two grand which I was okay with but she
wasn't up for just getting rid of or
just getting back to two grand if she
won't do that you're gonna have to hire
an attorney and force her to